so you never
have you experienced fear during
flight like um
i mean one one way we just offline
mentioning mike tyson
he talked about like uh as he's uh
walking up to the ring he's like
he starts out basically in fear
and uh yeah worried about how things are
going to go i mean it's
purely to put into words as fear but as
he gets closer and closer to the ring is
the confidence grows and grows until the
ego basically takes over to where you
think there's no way
anybody could uh defeat me
so like that's that's his experience of
overcoming fear but
do you uh did you experience any kind of
thing like that or is that
or do you just go to the part of the
brain that goes to the training
and then you just go to the instinctual
80 solution
i wouldn't say i was never afraid i
think that would be
i can i couldn't tell you that anyone i
know that wasn't afraid at one time and
for most of us especially navy carrier
pilots it's just it's it's usually
especially when you're new and you gotta
go out and it's night time and there's
no moon
and the weather sucks and the deck's
moving you know the ship's going up and
down
because it will scare over living [ __ ]
out of you can i say that
you can definitely say that so it's
about landing and takeoff that
that is if you even they used to wire
people up they did it during vietnam
you know guys to go fly missions you
know when they were flying low and crazy
stuff was going on and
people were getting shot down a lot uh
the highest
the highest anxiety and heart rates were
coming back to land on board an aircraft
carrier how hard is it to land on that
it seems impossible like for for a
civilian i guess like me it just seems
crazy that a human can do that
the problem with night is and there's
different
degrees of night just like day i mean
there's the clear full moon night
you know where it's like ooh you know
this is not that bad
but you got to remember at night i think
everyone can associate with
you're driving in your car and it's just
a it's it's an overcast
dark night and you're on a country road
with no side lights
most people have a tendency to slow down
just
by nature of oh my god because you what
you'll do is you'll out drive your
headlights because it is so dark
you know and you can get outside you get
outside the city and get up into new
hampshire
especially when the roads are curving
you know and the lines probably aren't
that good
it's you know now take that and multiply
it by like a million
because you have no depth perception uh
what you think is fixed the runway
is actually moving up and down and left
to right
yeah oh and when it's really bad you can
actually see it move
and we have two systems uh you know
there was a there's an automatic system
that's actually uh it stabilizes with
the inertials on the ship
and then there's the ils now civilian
pilots will tell you that ils is a
precision approach which gives you
azimuth and glide slope you know you
come down you it's like a plus
on the carrier it's not it's really just
a beam that goes out and it's considered
a non-precision approach
it's it's not stabilized at all that and
i've been where you can actually watch
the needle and the and the
the tack hand needle will move there's
all kinds of stuff moving because the
base that it's all sitting on
is doing this and ships don't just go up
and down they
they do this so the bow goes up and down
and the tail like you normally see a
ship
and then there's so that's pitch and
then it has roll so it's doing this and
then it has heave so the whole boat
is going up and down while it's pitching
and rolling and you're gonna land on
that
um so and it's i mean i remember landing
as i was with chris
uh sado and uh chris and i we're off the
uss ranger which is now decommissioned
it's
sitting getting turned into razor blades
uh we're flying the old a6 and we come
in and it was off of san diego and it
was just
ugly night because san diego always has
a marine layer that is about 1200 feet
was lower than that that night
and it was pouring down rain it was an
el nino year and there's thunderstorms
all around it was just
craziest night i've ever seen out of san
diego and i remember landing
and your adrenaline is so high that
you're shaking i mean you literally
can't stop
and we had spun around out of the
landing area and we parked we caught the
six-pack so it's right in front of the
island so if you see an aircraft carrier
the island and the number of the ship on
it
we're sitting right in front of that and
we're looking at the landing area so
it's like
you get front row seats to the concert
and
and this this this ea 6b comes in
you know ugly pass he ends up catching a
one wire which is the first one you
never want to catch the first one which
means you were
not really high above the back of the
ship when you landed
and it comes in and the the exhaust on
an ea6 or an a6 actually points kind of
down
and it blows and it's blowing all the
standing water on the aircraft that's
how hard it's raining and you literally
could not see across i mean i could see
the front of my airplane his airplane
and then it was just white because of
the water being blown off the deck
and i'm shaking and i like i'll never
forget i looked over at chris and i said
oh my god i go hey dude man 10
000 foot runway looks really good right
now and i go and i'm
shaking my hands like this and i said
i'm not even this is i'm not faking this
dude i know that's literally i cannot
stop shaking
i said that scared the evil out of me
yeah um
but you but it scares you afterwards
you don't during it you're not i'm not
you don't have time to think about that
you're doing it you got to do
this you know kind of the quote from tom
hanks and uh
what's that uh the girls baseball movie
where he goes there's no crying in
baseball oh yeah that's our joke there's
no crying in naval aviation i said
you can fly around and cry all you want
at night but you know there's only one
pilot in those airplanes and you got to
land it so
you can try all you wipe the tears away
you know put on your big kid pants and
it's it's time to
it's time to you know man up and land
atlanta jet
you